[Music]
the ocean is a magnificent inhospitable
place cold dark and violent it is an
environment that people have contended
with frezz long as humanity has existed
many have traversed the oceans surface
but only relatively recently have we
begun to grapple with the final frontier
of the sea but deep as you descend
deeper and deeper into the ocean the
laws of physics are instantly and
harshly working against you most of the
visible light spectrum is absorbed
within 10 metres of the water's surface
and almost none penetrates below 150
metres even when the water is very clear
and as you go deeper the temperature
falls and the pressure quickly becomes
immense every 10 metres adds another one
atmosphere of pressure recreational
divers can safely descend to 33 metres
on the way down your ears have to be
equalized constantly and slowly but
surely everything becomes more and more
blue as the other colors of visible
light disappear nitrogen narcosis can
start to set in and even at this
relatively shallow depth the surface can
feel distressingly far away but deeper
than this much much deeper there is work
to be done
precise technical work that requires
sharp concentration and hours of
manpower working so far below the
surface should be outside the realm of
human capability and yet every day the
ocean floor is occupied by men and
bizarre suits carrying out extremely
difficult work so how is it exactly that
we can send people down to these depths
to complete complicated tasks sometimes
working underwater for hours at a time
what science is involved in this
dangerous but essential job that enables
these divers to stay alive commercial
divers work to maintain offshore oil
rigs and pipelines completing tasks that
require more precision and
maneuverability than a remotely operated
vehicle can manage
divers are needed to flip flow valves
both pipes together or clear debris the
work is essentially heavy-duty
construction that happens to be under
the sea it's an isolated and dangerous
job and often involves working
underwater at depths of up to 500 meters
there is danger in being so far below
the surface relying on your hoses for
your air supply heat and communications
and dealing with heavy construction
materials but much of the danger the
divers deal with does not come from the
cold dark deep itself but rather
returning from it decompression sickness
or the bends is a debilitating disorder
that happens from a rapid decrease in
pressure on the body causing gases that
were dissolved in tissue to form
life-threatening bubbles any diver has
to be very careful to avoid this
dangerous phenomenon but for divers
working extremely deep and for long
periods if left unchecked decompression
sickness would be definitively fatal air
is made up of roughly 78% nitrogen and
22% oxygen normally on the surface we
simply breathe out the nitrogen that we
inhale since our bodies don't use it but
when diving at depth each breath taken
contains many more molecules of oxygen
and nitrogen than a breath taken at the
surface due to the increased pressure
and with all these extra molecules
entering the lungs they begin to
accumulate in the body as the pressure
increases the nitrogen gas into solution
and more and more of it dissolves into
the body's tissues this dissolved
nitrogen is luckily harmless in our
bodies if we stay under pressure but
when it's time to come back to the
surface the problem begins as the
outside pressure decreases during ascent
from a dive the accumulated nitrogen
forms bubbles in the blood and tissues
this is because gas comes out of
solution when pressure decreases just
like when you open a bottle of soda and
if these bubbles are too big or formed
too quickly they can injure tissue or
even block blood vessels the blood
vessel blockage causes pain and in the
worst instances death in regular diving
this risk is mitigated by coming up to
the surface gradually allowing the
nitrogen to diffuse slowly out of tissue
and be exhaled through the lungs
avoiding the build-up of big nitrogen
bubbles diving to 75 meters for an hour
for example would require a five hour
ascent to avoid getting bent and the
longer the dive the more dissolved
nitrogen has built up in the tissue and
so the longer the decompression time
needed for deep-sea divers working at
depths much greater than this and for
many more hours the amount of time it
would take to safely ascend would be way
too long to be feasible and on top of
the deadly effect of decompression
sickness nitrogen plays other tricks on
the body
nitrogen narcosis is a condition that
hits many divers when doing deeper dives
usually setting in around 30 meters at
this step it can cause an alteration and
consciousness basically giving you the
feeling of being drunk it's usually not
harmful in and of itself but slowed
mental activity giddiness and
overconfidence can lead to divers
disregarding safe diving practices at 30
meters on a recreational dive the
effects are kind of amusing and can be
simply reversed by ascending a few
meters but as you go deeper and deeper
the effect can be debilitating and
mental impairment may become extremely
hazardous below 90 meters it can lead to
hallucinations loss of memory or in
consciousness which for deep-sea divers
working on intricate and dangerous tasks
could quickly become fatal scientists
don't fully understand what causes it
but believe nitrogen gas or any inert
gas except helium and probably neon
react with lipids or fat tissues which
make up most of the brain causing an
effect and so because of the tricky
interaction between the physics of gases
and physiology of the body for a long
time deep sea dives remained out of
reach but this all changed in the 1960s
as NASA was launching its effort to put
men on the moon the Office of Naval
Research was working on their own
otherworldly mission putting men at the
bottom of the ocean in July of 1964 an
odd-looking vessel was launched from the
Navy's oceanographic research tower off
the island of Bermuda where it sank to a
depth of 60 meters 12 hours later for
Navy divers entered the sea lab one
ready to begin a unique 21-day
experiment their assignment was to
participate in the Navy's first extended
physiological tests to determine how men
can work freely and for long periods
deep below the surface the primary
mission of the Sealab project was to see
if time-wasting dangerous daily
decompressions while returning to the
surface could be eliminated by providing
a shelter near the dive location capped
at a pressure equal to the diving
pressure this would in theory allow the
men to work for longer and at greater
depths as I mentioned before when under
pressure every breath you take contains
more molecules of nitrogen and oxygen
than on the surface and the extra
nitrogen dissolves in your tissues but
after enough time at a certain pressure
the body can't absorb anymore and
becomes fully saturated with it more
time at that depth will not add any more
nitrogen to the tissue and thus more
bottom time will not add to the length
of the decompression time because of
this divers can stay pressurized
indefinitely working multiple long dives
while only needing one long
decompression after days weeks or even
months of time below the surface
this type of diving was coined
saturation diving and is much safer than
making multiple short dives that each
require their own lengthy decompression
the dives can also be deeper and longer
since decompression can happen in a
controlled habitat however while
decompression sickness is managed with
this method it does not solve the
problem of nitrogen narcosis nitrogen
breathed at depth would still be
incapacitating underwater or in the
living quarters to avoid this problem
saturation divers don't breathe normal
air instead they breathe a gas cocktail
called heliox which replaces most of the
nitrogen in normal air with helium
helium does not cause the narcotic
effect that nitrogen does and is
harmless to the human body
decompression from a heliox saturation
dive also requires less time than would
be required with an air mixture that
contains more nitrogen however breathing
helium does not come without its own
consequences and sounds exactly as silly
as you would think
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and while amusing to those of us who
don't have to deal with it for weeks on
end it can become annoying and actually
problematic it's hard to understand
people over the communication systems
with these voices so surface personnel
often have to use a piece of equipment
called a helium descrambler which
electronically lowers the pitch of the
divers voice after a series of Sealab
experiments it soon became apparent that
it would be easier and cheaper to
monitor and support the divers if the
pressurized living quarters weren't
actually at the bottom of the sea but
instead onboard the dive support vessels
and kept at pressure mechanically divers
enter the chambers and the blowdown
begins slowly and carefully the pressure
increases to match the pressure they
will experience at working depth after
around 72 hours
the divers bodies become saturated with
the inert gas to get to the sea floor
divers exit their pressure chamber
habitats through an airlock and enter a
diving bell which is also pressurized
the diving bell is then lowered to the
required working depth and the divers
exit the diving bell into the cold dark
water to work once the divers have
finished their shift they re-enter the
Bell which is hoisted back to the
surface and the next shift can begin and
while physically close to the others
aboard the dive support vessel they may
as well be in space the general rule for
desaturation is 24 hours for each 33
meters of pressure so it can take days
to decompress from a deep dive and
rejoin society if done carefully and if
there are no catastrophic equipment
failures saturation diving can be done
safely
however the divers have to remain in a
pressurized environment for the duration
of their work time which can be as long
as three weeks or more this means living
in very close quarters with other divers
with no privacy whatsoever mentally and
physically it is extremely taxing
and while mostly safe due to
advancements in protocols and technology
it is not without its dangers if an
airlock fails the pressure would
explosively decrease and bubbles would
rapidly form in the blood basically
boiling it bodies can be and have been
shot out through any opening no matter
how small it is immediately and
gruesomely fatal and even with rigorous
safety protocols in place decompression
is still hard on the body and still
comes with a lot of danger when
undergoing g saturation divers report
joint pain headaches and shortness of
breath and these symptoms are
unfortunately similar to the first
symptoms of decompression sickness
experienced divers know the difference
but if any diver thinks they may be
suffering from the bends the whole team
will have to start the decompression
again the only cure for early signs of
decompression sickness is to return to
higher pressure saturation diving is not
for the faint of heart
there is an ever-present sense of danger
exiting the diving bell and entering a
pitch-black underwater world is enough
to make anyone squeamish and the days
and weeks on end spent and confined
quarters would be enough to make most
people go mad but what if there was a
way to eliminate the need for these
claustrophobic pressure chambers what if
there was a way to get rid of the risk
of the bends and lengthy decompression
times all together in part two of this
video I will explore one of the craziest
concepts in modern science so strange
that it sounds like sci-fi liquid
breathing it flips everything we just
discussed about the human body in a deep
water environment on its head and could
revolutionize diving medicine and space
travel as we know it
pushing the limits of the human body is
something that people have been doing
for as long as humanity has existed
flying climbing or diving we can't seem
to resist the pole of extreme
environments deep-sea divers certainly
push these boundaries and breathing
liquid could one day allow these crazy
people to go even deeper if you like
learning about these extreme pursuits
then you should check out the human
limits documentary series on curiosity
stream curiosity stream is a streaming
platform that has thousands of high
quality high budget documentaries and
the human limit series highlights people
with extraordinary skills that go beyond
what is usually deemed humanly possible
the physical masters episode is
particularly interesting and
investigates the life of a free diver
with extraordinary lung capacity a woman
who climbs sheer ice Peaks and a blind
man who sees through echolocation among
other people with super capabilities and
if you're a fan of educational content
and looking for more quality things to
watch during your quarantine then this
is the perfect time to sign up because a
subscription to curiosity stream and now
comes with a subscription to nebula
nebula is a place for top educational
content creators like polyphonic
Wendover productions and our other
channel real engineering can create
videos freely without worrying about the
YouTube algorithm or D monetization it's
a place where we can upload our content
ad free and also experiment with
original content and new series the
original content is my favorite part of
nebula shows like Tom Scott's game show
money where he pits a bunch of youtubers
against each other in psychological
experiments or real engineering
logistics of d-day series which has a
new episode out today about the aerial
landings that helped make d-day s
so if you sign up for curiosity stream
at curiosity stream comm slash real
science you'll get a subscription to
curiosity stream and a subscription to
nebula for a year for just $19.99 by
signing up you're not just supporting
this channel but all of your favorite
educational content creators thanks for
watching and if you would like to see
more from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter and patreon are below
[Music]